hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten mills ihr habt ihr bereits schon
mitbekommen dass ich ein großer kürbis
fan bin und deswegen gibt es heute eine
leckere kürbissuppe und diese
kürbissuppe ist ganz besonders lecker
weil ich somit etwas orangensaft mache
also die schmeckt dann nicht nur lecker
nach kürbis sondern einfach auch ein
bisschen fruchtig und ich sage ich jetzt
einfach mal die zutaten für etwa vier
personen
ich habe hier ein stückchen butter das
sind ungefähr zehn gramm einen esslöffel
zucker ein stück irgendwas müssen
ungefähr zehn bis 15 gramm sein einen
halben teelöffel currypulver 250
milliliter wasser und ein brühwürfel da
könnte auch einfach 250 milliliter
gemüsebrühe nehmen
ich habe hier noch ein paar chiliflocken
mit drin wer es gerne ein bisschen
scharf mag einen kürbis da nehme ich
aber nur 500 gramm davon
und hier habe ich noch 200 milliliter
orangensaft und 100 milliliter sahne zum
vorbereiten nehme ich jetzt hier meinen
kürbis und halbieren
und es geht ein bisschen schwierig weil
dass er hart ist und ich habe auch jetzt
hier wieder ein hokkaidokürbis genommen
weil ich den nicht stehlen muss da kann
ich die schale mit benutzen weil die
schale schönwald wird dann entfernt ich
werde das innere das geht ganz gut mit
einem löffel
und hier entferne ich einfach noch so
diese harten stellen
und das restliche fruchtfleisch würfeln
ich jetzt einfach in etwa ein zentimeter
große stücke
einen topf erhitzt sich es schon mal und
gibt da jetzt das gewürfelte
fruchtfleisch hinein
es darf schon mal ein bisschen an räumen
mit sehr gut ab
hier gebe ich jetzt noch den zucker
meter zu damit es so ein bisschen
karamellisierte und auch das currypulver
damit sich der geschmack richtig
entfalten kann
und das lasse ich jetzt so etwa drei bis
vier minuten dünsten und dann geht es
gleich weiter
und jetzt kann es hier noch den ingwer
schälen und werden kurz kleinen stücken
und mit acg
den kürbis lösch es jetzt mit dem wasser
ab gibt damit den orangensaft dazu und
den prügel für und dann muss das jetzt
aufkochen und wird dann etwa 20 minuten
gekocht bis eben der kürbis weich ist
und dann können wir die suppe
fertigstellen
mein kürbisse sitzt weiß gekocht ich
hatte auch den deckel auf dem topf drauf
und jetzt kann ich ihn fein pürieren das
mache ich jetzt einfach mit einem
pürierstab einmal durch
und dann sollte das ganze schon ziemlich
dick flüssig sein
und jetzt kommt ja noch die sahne dazu
wird nochmal kurz verrührt und jetzt
kochen wir das nicht mehr damit die
sahne dann darin nicht gerinnt und jetzt
dürfte noch abschmecken mit etwas salz
und pfeffer
und wenn dann der geschmack stimmt ist
die suppe fertig
ich brauche nur noch ein bisschen salz
im nachsetzen kann ja jeder selber am
tisch dann dürfte die suppe servieren
und ich gehe immer gern noch ein
bisschen von diesem kürbiskernöl mit
rein
es gibt erstens noch mal so eine schöne
würze und 42 aus
warum
und dann ist die suppe fertig ich es
super am liebsten pur aber man könnte
zum beispiel auch so ein paar
hähnchenspieße machen und die dazu geben
oder einfach ein bisschen geröstetes
brot das rezept gibt es natürlich zum
nachlesen auch sehr liest orten welt.de
und ich würde mich freuen wenn ich das
mal ausprobiert auch wenn ihr keine
kürbis fenster das sich auch immer
wieder dazu ich finde kürbis total
lecker und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachkochen und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder bis bald